FIRES.
AND WE ARE G G
WATCHED BY GARLAND.
IN THE AIR, UP AND IN, OKORO
DRAWS THE FOUL KNOCKS IT DOWN.
OKORO.
GOOD CATCH UNDERNEAEA120-111.
THEY PUSH IT, POKUSEVSKI LAYS I
BLOCKED, THAT'SHOOTS 81% FROM T
STRIPE.
JOHNSON TO TRIGGER. YOU HIT THE
RIM.
SOMETHING OFTEN  TIME-OUTS FOR .
GIANNIS
SPRINTING TO CHALLENGE.
THIS IS THAT TWO, AND YOU BIG TE
MI Ryan: O'NEALE OUT OF
O'NEALE.
FIVE SECONDS TO GO,T COUNTS.
>> RULING TON FLOOR IS
CONFIRMED.
>> PASCAL TO BARNES.
MISSES.
COMES UP WITH IT.NG THE HANDS
TAPPED OUT.
RAPTORS HAVE A FOUL TO GIVE.
THERE'S A TIM
AND THEAD
PASS.
>> Mike: HOW ABOUT HHE DRIVE AN
THE FINISH.
THYBULLE WILL COME IN.
IF  IT.
BACK.
LAY-UP WON'T GO. THE OTHER NIGH
TORONTO,HARDEN.
SHOT CLOCK AT TWO.
ANTHONY AGAIN.
HE IS OFFICIALLY ON  Y PUTS IT
POINT GAME.
WAGNER, 1 OUT Y, LOOKING FOR A
NO GOOD AT TH
TRENT JR. WILL DRIBBLE IT
GOODNIGHT,  TRIPLE
DOWN THE STRETCH.
AND THE MAVS GOING TO CALL DONC
SHOT.
THEY'RE GOING TO CALL HIM
CORNER.
FINNEY-SMITH PENETRATESS TALKIN.
HERE IS DURANT.
MAVS DO HAVEEE
THREES